let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right so who's the latest politician
to violate his own covet rules
and get caught for doing it important
qualifier here you know that is
get caught for doing it because we can
assume that they're all violating the
rules
it's just that they don't all get caught
so the latest is governor gavin newsom
in california um he went to a party
at a restaurant so that's two levels
here what he went to a restaurant
and it was a party um and uh and i guess
he was caught people found out about it
and here he is pretending to be contrite
a few weeks ago i was asked to go to a
friend's 50th birthday
my wife and i friend that i've known for
almost 20 years and
uh and a friend that had invite well put
a lot of
time and energy into his 50th birthday
it was in napa which was in the orange
status relatively loose compared to some
other counties
it was to be an outdoor restaurant
and we started the well the program
started at four o'clock it was one of
those early
reservations i got there a little bit
late at 4 30
and as soon as i sat down at the larger
table i realized it was a little larger
group
than i had anticipated and i made a bad
mistake
instead of sitting down i should have
stood up and walked back got in my car
and drove back
uh to my house instead i chose to sit
there with my wife
and a number of other couples that were
outside the household and you can
quibble about
the guidelines et cetera et cetera but
the spirit of what i'm preaching all the
time
was contradicted and i got to own that
and so i want to apologize to you
because i need to preach and practice
not just preach and not practice and
i've done my best to do that
we're all human we all fall short
sometimes
i saw somebody on twitter point out that
there's a real disconnect
um really in general with this guy but
especially in that clip you just watched
between his facial expressions and what
he's saying
he's he's supposed to be apologetic but
you don't see that on his face
uh he keeps saying well we all you know
i made a mistake we all make mistakes
yeah sure we all do make mistakes but
going to a party
while at the same time forbidding the
residents of your state from doing the
same
is not a mistake it's an intentional act
this word mistake is often abused i
think um a mistake is something you do
you didn't mean to do right it's like an
accident
if you do it intentionally it's not a
mistake so this was an intentional
act on the part of the governor and we
have a right to ask
what motivated this intention like it's
not enough with these with these people
when they get caught doing this whether
they're going to get their hair done
or they're going to a party whatever it
is um you see them walking around
without a mask even while they're
lecturing everybody else for not having
masks on
passing mask mandates and everything um
we have a right to it's not enough to
say oh it's a mistake i'm so sorry okay
great you're sorry
you're sorry because you were caught but
why were you doing it what
what what motivated that we have a right
to ask
that so we could ask with governor
newsom
is he suicidal and homicidal does he
really believe that going to an event
like this
might kill someone or himself and he did
it anyway because that's
that's the way he talks normally
if so you know if he's homicidal and
suicidal that's a fact that might be of
some interest to
the people of california or does he not
really believe
what he says about the virus does he
actually believe that
well sure you mean you you can you can
be you know
pretty safe and go to a restaurant go to
a party like it's possible to do
does he is that is that the case which
means that everything he's been saying
about the virus publicly he doesn't
really mean
it's got to be one of those right it's
either he doesn't he doesn't believe
what he's been saying about the virus or
he does believe it
and he's got a death wish it really has
to be one or the other
and uh that's i i think if there was a
real media in this country
and in california especially they would
ask him that question which is a
governor do you have a death wish or
are you a a lying hypocrite which one
i think it's probably the lying
hypocrite one
number two a huge scandal here uh the
daily beast has this covered
it says madison cawthorne the north
carolina republican who became the
youngest member of congress in history
has admitted that he tried to convert
jews and muslims to christianity
my god in an interview with jewish
insider
the 25 year old who came under fire for
selfies he took at hitler's vacation
retreat in germany
claimed he had converted several muslims
to christ and several culturally jewish
people
catherine said if all if all you are is
friends with other christians then
how are you ever going to lead somebody
to christ if you're not wanting to lead
someone to christ
then you're probably not really a
christian claiming he's read through
just about every single religious work
there is
the republican said that he converted a
young woman from new york
and someone quote down in atlanta when
he was in rehab after a car accident the
left and paralyzed
it was pretty incredible hawthorne added
as um
and and said he has been unsuccessful in
converting practicing jews
but he has quote switched a lot of i
guess
culturally jewish people but being a
practicing jew like people who are
religious about it they are very
difficult i've had a hard time
connecting with them in that way
okay disturbing stuff
it seems that this evangelical christian
believes in evangelizing it seems that
this believer in the good news believes
in telling people the good news
it seems that this christian is
christian
incredible revelation i'm glad that
daily beast is on top of this
perhaps next we'll find out that you
know there are vegetarians out there who
like salad
uh bowlers who on occasion will roll
heavy balls towards
small stationary objects i mean it's
impossible to know what surprises
await us after this um by the way if
you've ever been just just a note here
if you've if you've if you've ever been
proselytized to
um whether you're a member of a
non-christian religion
or no religion you shouldn't be offended
by it or upset by it it doesn't make any
sense to be offended or upset by it
the person trying to convert you
believes they are telling you a crucial
truth about the
universe and reality um you may disagree
you know you may not believe what
they're saying but there's no place to
be offended by it
you should be offended if they don't
tell you if they don't share it with you
you know if you've got a christian in
your life who's who's uh who's not
sharing
that with you i think i think that maybe
is where the offense should come in
um i think that tells you something
about how much they care about you
and for you it's sort of like you know
if you're if you're walking towards a
bridge
and someone thinks that the bridge is
faulty and it's going to give way if you
walk over it
they should tell you that and you should
be very offended
if they don't tell you that even if
they're wrong about the status of the
bridge
like you're walking over the bridge and
there's someone who sees you walking
they stay silent
and then as soon as you make it over
they shout to you oh phew
i thought that bridge was going to give
out well you would be right to respond
dude then why didn't you tell me that
before i walked across it
so you were prepared to just watch me
fall to my death
that's kind of what it's like but in
this case of course it's the other way
around where the christian believes
they're they are you know
they are pointing to a bridge that will
not give way
when they share the gospel they are
trying to steer you towards the sturdy
bridge
and again even if you don't believe what
they're saying there's no cause
for offense any more than
you know in in other religions or some
other religions
there's not as much evangelizing that
goes on christianity is
uh somewhat unique on that front but if
i'm talking to someone of another
religion as has happened and they're
trying to convince me of the truth of
their religion doesn't offend me
at all um all right let's go here
and and here's another not so shocking
revelation since we're on the subject of
things that shouldn't shock us another
hate crime claim is has been exposed as
a hoax
it says um
let's see this is from the daily wire
yes clifton utzi
18 claimed that his bmw x5 was
vandalized as part of a hate crime
with the perpetrator writing um
every message that left-wing
provocateurs think the wright believes
they spray painted across the suv
racist and homophobic slurs including
the n-word
and kkk was sprayed across
the car as well as anti-black lives
matter messages
um i think there was a swastika
too but a month after the initial story
gained local media headlines i never
even heard about this
um the owner of the vehicle has now been
charged with multiple crimes in relation
to the incident
uh insurance fraud uh filing a flaw
false claim but a bunch of other charges
so
it's it's good that they're actually
being charged with a crime for a change
because usually that's not how these
things go
uh he faces up to seven years in prison
no way he's actually gonna get seven
years in prison but i would like to see
that happen
if you really want to put an end to
these hate crime false hate crime
claims which seem to happen every week
now um there need to be
serious ramifications for people to do
this
and it is a serious crime you know to my
mind
if you file a false hate crime claim you
should
get the penalty that
somebody would have gotten for
committing that hate crime if it really
happened
so if somebody had actually defaced this
guy's
car with kkk and swastikas and you know
racial slurs and everything
then whatever whatever penalty they
would get and i'm sure it would be
several years in prison
that's the penalty that this person
should get to my mind
but this you know like like we talk
about where the
the uh the desire for
hate crimes and for racism uh
you know is is there's a greater desire
for it than there is a supply of it
and it also just shows the people that
that that
come up with these fake hate crimes not
only
the fact that that they're doing a fake
hate crime in the first place tells you
something
because if we really lived in a racist
country and you for some reason
wanted to be a victim of a hate crime uh
there should probably be plenty of
opportunities for it to really happen to
you
but it's not just that it's also just
that this would appear to be someone
who's just never encountered an actual
racist person in their life
because they have no idea what an actual
racist person would say or how they
would act
that's what you find in the hate crime
hoaxers they they they
such as that they've never been a victim
of a real hate crime it seems like and
this is good this is good news
they've never encountered actual racism
because they have no they have this
cartoonish idea
they get their idea of racism from tv
from the movies like an
actual racist person would spray paint
kkk
and a swat sticker on your on your card
no
um so that's the good news we should we
should all we should all
be happy that racism is not nearly as
prevalent as the left likes to pretend
uh what else here from the new york post
it says americans who are hosting
gatherings over the holiday season
should encourage guests not to sing
while inside and should shield their
pets from interacting with guests
from outside their household according
to guidance from the cdc
the recommendations were included in a
list of guidelines by the agency to help
stop the spread of chronovirus as a
second wave
has spread like wildfire across the u.s
um
cdc is said encourage guests to avoid
singing or shouting especially indoors
keep music levels down so people don't
have to shout or speak loudly to be
heard
then it goes on from there with other
the cdc sounds like me talking to my
kids no shouting keep the noise down
hey no jumping on the couches those
aren't trampolines
um this is obviously absurd but i do
have two thoughts here
first of all who who is singing at their
holiday parties do people actually do
that
like in it's a wonderful life or
something where the whole
the whole crowd starts singing together
in unison i've never seen that i've i've
heard music at holiday parties i've been
to plenty of holiday parties in my life
i've never actually i don't think i've
ever actually seen a group of people
start singing
um number two i'm actually in favor
maybe this would surprise you um
i'm i'm in favor on a couple levels here
of this
first of all the thing about keeping
your pets away from the guests
totally in favor of that it's got
nothing to do with coven for me though
when i go over to your house and you
have a dog i'm sorry like i know you
love your dog and you think everyone
else does
i don't need your dog jumping on me
every five seconds it's super annoying
and it's always awkward when the person
who owns the dog is not
they just assume that we all they just
assumed that i would just love to have
this slobbering beast crawling all over
me for the entire night
why would you assume i'd want that
um so that's that's good advice and the
second good advice i think is
banning singing and music at christmas
i'm actually in favor of that
as long as it's more targeted uh so
what i would say is ban certain songs
like band
wonderful christmas time little drummer
boy
anything sung by mariah carey those
songs from what i understand
are um you know those are songs that
that if you sing them or listen to them
you're more at risk to spread covet i
think i think that's
that's the science they can also cause
bubonic plague hepatitis tetanus
so best to play it safe and ban just
those songs the rest of the christmas
music
have at it um number five finally
i'm i'm concerned about japan very
concerned
um someone needs to have a talk with
japan
this it would appear is a very lonely
country
uh we already know about all the sex
robots in japan that's a big thing
last i read 67 of the population in
japan is now comprised of
sex robots um and i just made that up
but here's something i'm not making up
a new invention for single men in japan
here it is here you can see it it's a
robotic hand
which just to clarify the robotic hand
is uh
is is meant to simulate hand holding for
single guys in japan
and you see it says you could take a
romantic stroll with this robotic head
it's uh if you can't see if you're if
you're listening to the audio podcast
it's a
it's like a severed hand um
but it's robotic and you kind of like
strap it to yourself
and it says it feels almost like a real
female hand supposedly
i'm not sure how much it costs the good
news is that at least
however much it costs it's sure to be
cheaper than an actual girlfriend so
that's the one positive
if you can deal with looking like a
serial killer when you walk down the
street
um then maybe this is the way to go i
just feel like
some other country needs to reach out to
japan at this point
and say like listen guys if you need a
friend
we could be pen pals you know this is
just
this is just not not healthy at all well
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
matt walsh show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content